it is finally happening Apple just
announced Final Cut Pro coming to the
iPad along with logic as well now we
have a bunch of information but what is
interesting are the things that Apple
didn't mention so in this video I'm
gonna be going through all of the cool
updates for Final Cut on iPad and
believe it or not a lot of these things
are actually better than on the Mac now
let's get this out of the way this Final
Cut will not be available to buy one
time it is gonna cost you five bucks a
month or a yearly 49 purchase which
sucks because on the Mac I bought Final
Cut eight nine ten years ago and I get
all the updates for free but at the same
time it's five bucks a month it's not
300 and you can cancel month-to-month if
you're going with that plan now this is
going to be coming out May 23rd so we
are very close now let me show you guys
some of the killer features now on the
right hand side we have the jog wheel
now if you've seen professional high-end
setups they will have a jog wheel that
makes it easy and quick to move through
your timeline and this has a built-in on
the right hand side super convenient and
of course you can use the apple pencil
or your finger because this has a new
touch screen interface now Blackmagic
design released DaVinci Resolve for iPad
and I showed off how nice it is to use
the apple pencil video editing on this
is going to be excellent and with that
here's something that we are so excited
for the ability to draw on your display
and have easy quick animations that are
playing back with your video this is so
much nicer and easier to use than trying
to do keyframes and animations on a
desktop and of course you can combine
that with Apple's keyboards to have
shortcuts and edit both ways now one of
the things they didn't mention is how
this is going to integrate with Final
Cut we see here that you can import from
iMovie which is a given but I look
through everything and what I found is
that you can export to your Mac that has
Final Cut but they are not allowing you
to import from your Mac to the iPad
which is what I would like to do to be
able to do some of those drawings on the
screen you know draw some arrows to help
you guys visually see what I'm talking
about but it doesn't look like they want
you to do that now you guys know that
the 12.9 inch iPad has that mini LED HDR
display that hits 1600 Peak knits of
brightness it is an amazing display and
now you'll be able to work with HDR
content edit and Visually see it the way
it's supposed to be and then of course
export that out and unlike a lot of
other apps for your exporting you have a
lot of options here to choose from
they're not limiting you now let me
share some of the things I'm most
excited about and first off we have
voice isolation we have this in the
iPhone when you're talking to somebody
it can actually now pull your voice out
give it a background noise and you could
do this with regular clips that are
there we also have scene removal where
you can cut out a subject from the
background and then put anything else
that you want there these are things
that we do not have on the Mac version
of Final Cup Pro so it's really cool to
see that in the fact that the neural
engine on these M1 and M2 chips are
being used so here's another thing that
you don't really easily see on this page
and that is the fact that you need to
have at least an M1 chip in your iPad or
an M2 to be able to use this program now
logic that one goes all the way back to
think that a12 doesn't that need that
much power but because of Final Cut I
think that a lot of people are going to
want to upgrade their iPads we also have
Auto crop where it will take your video
and make into a vertical format to share
online which is very cool also using the
neural engine and the multicam editing
also seems to be very good it will
synchronize your video with your audio
and I really like how they put the
little strip down here at the bottom
instead of the side it saves you a lot
of space and then as you're editing you
can go ahead and switch through between
angles and then adjust all your audio as
well it looks to be very well made of
course you're going to get a bunch of
transitions titles all that built in but
the ones that they show off I mean
they're kind of cheesy just like in
Final Cut you guys can see these right
here I mean they're okay we use a few of
them but what is more important is that
you'll be able to use third-party
plugins like from motion VFX here at the
mentioned third-party content and that
could be you know pictures animation
video but what they don't show off there
is if you scroll all the way down they
literally say some of these templates
are from motion VFX so we love motion
VFX we use it all the time and you're
going to be able to have a lot of extra
stuff just like you would on Mac OS now
the cameras on the iPads are not that
good they are years behind the iPhones
especially the 48 megapixel ones where
cinematic mode actually looks really
really good but with that they are
building in the ability to be able to
record right in Final Cut and you have
great manual controls which we normally
wouldn't have so you can adjust a lot of
your settings you can see what you're
recording the audio you can even shoot
in prores and then directly go right
into your timeline so hopefully the
newer iPads that will come out will have
that a 48 megapixel sensor with the new
software and then it will be usable like
we're shooting stuff on iPhone right now
and it looks fantastic even for our
YouTube videos and take a look at this
here they're saying you shoot cinematic
mode on iPhone and then in the actual
program you can change the focus or even
remove it that's why we need the better
cameras here but that is such a cool
feature to have built in because it's a
pain going to your iPhone adjusting it
sending it back to your computer to your
Mac putting it in this is awesome and
there are so many other things they
could do including prores Rock crazy you
have good color grading tools
um Scopes there keyframes I mean a ton
of stuff and then you can also send it
out to Final Cut when this right here
also tells us in a way that they are not
trying to replace the Mac version with
this I don't want to call it Final Cut
light for the iPad but there are going
to be more features on Mac that you
would still want to have a Macbook and
an iPad of course that's Apple they like
to make money and another thing they
don't mention but if you look in the
fine print this requires Final Cut
10.10.6 which is not out yet but that
also tells us that they are going to
release a new version of Final Cut at
the time that this software is going to
be released now another thing they did
not mention but we could take from this
is that WWDC will be absolutely packed
the video they showed off for this
launch would have been perfect at WWDC
that's a software developer conference
but they chose to release this with a
little press release because they have
so many different products software
things coming out WWDC that is just way
too packed so we know that WWDC is going
to be absolutely great this year not
boring like some previous ones so are
you going to be upgrading to do an iPad
with an M1 or an M2 Chip to be able to
use Final Cut if you don't have one of
those already and what are your thoughts
let me know in the comments section
below click that Circle to subscribe
check out one of those videos right over
there this has been Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign